el 5 de febrero la campaña de trompo
tomaba un nuevo impulso el senado lo
absolvió de los cargos de abuso de poder
y obstrucción al congreso a raíz de las
presiones a ucrania para beneficiarse
electoralmente dos tercios de los
senadores presentes no lo encontraron
culpable de los cargos mencionados
después de las derrotas en iowa y new
hampshire ganar en carolina del sur el
29 de febrero puso a wide n de nuevo la
batalla por la nominación demócrata a la
presidencia y se consolidó tras el
retiro del senador bernie sanders en
abril
después de restar importancia al virus
como un milagro desaparecerá el 13 de
marzo
declaró la emergencia nacional eeuu se
convirtió en el país con más contagios
en el mundo y tanto la campaña electoral
como el comercio y la vida normal se
paralizaron por un tiempo la gestión de
trump de la pandemia se convirtió en un
tema clave en la contienda y es una de
las razones de la alta votación
anticipada en los comicios la muerte del
afroamericano a causa de la brutalidad
policial el 25 de mayo provocó una ola
de protestas en todo el país
convirtiendo el tema de la
discriminación racial y la brutalidad
policial en uno predominante la senadora
por california aceptó el 11 de agosto
ser su compañera de fórmula para la
vicepresidencia pronto demostró ser lo
que necesitaba una voz fresca e
influyente que energizar a la base
demócrata los peores temores de los
liberales se cumplieron cuando la jueza
sucumbió ante el cáncer dos meses antes
de los comicios rompo la nominó a miconi
partners que fue confirmada el 27 de
octubre acentuando la tendencia
conservadora en la corte suprema- el 29
de septiembre quedará la memoria de los
estadounidenses por la beligerancia del
debate
de nitro que se ha salido de control el
encuentro fue ampliamente rechazado por
el público y los actores políticos
[Aplausos]
después de negarse a usar la máscara y
de realizar masivos mítines
trump fue diagnosticado con kobe 19 el 2
de octubre y estuvo alejado de la
campaña por 10 días
su diagnóstico hizo que se agudizará las
críticas en su contra y que el virus
siguiera siendo un tema central en las
elecciones